hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday Monday December 4th 2004 17 yeah
there we go I just realized I just gave
a [ __ ] and just gave dean del rey a
check and I wrote December 5th on it I
thought tomorrow is December 5th well it
is by the time you hear this but I did
this Sunday night now [ __ ] it's all not
to deposit to check well they can still
deposit it right and then they don't
[ __ ] in whatever D del Rey opened for me
this weekend holy [ __ ] we got the levels
up too high here they're too high I
can't hear myself thinking here for
God's sakes could you just shut it down
please thank you dude a [ __ ] sitting
there one dude I'm sitting there minding
my own business
in my house my [ __ ] house [ __ ] you
bankers it's mine now until I die and
then you get it back don't you get [ __ ]
they just sit there waiting if you ever
pay off you look out your window
there'll be a banker sitting out there
like a [ __ ] like a goddamn vulture
waiting feet at [ __ ] look at them
look at I'm eating bacon
I guess Bacon's good feet now I don't
know what the [ __ ] I don't know what I
know what I'm talking about
anyways I wonder what room I'm gonna die
in in this house you ever think about
that would you just get the house like
I'm not [ __ ] leaving I'm staying here
right and then you just when you once
you make that decision you're like well
then I'm gonna [ __ ] die in here what
room is it gonna be I think a lot of
people diet breakfast nook you know just
sitting down having some toast reading
the morning paper that would be a bad
way to go let's go face down it's like
[ __ ] a half piece of grapefruit all
right what would you want to die in you
don't want to do it in the shower right
that's [ __ ] awful then you're all
waterlogged you know bang your head on
the [ __ ] a lot of people died in the
shower they slip and fall you know and
they can't get up right and that's why
they came out with that [ __ ] that
thing there for all the old people
but what a lot of people don't realize
is a lot of them fall in the [ __ ]
shower and then they go to use their
little I've fallen and I can't get up
thing and then they get electrocuted I
don't think that happens but I would be
worried about that trying to drag my old
prune to ass out of the [ __ ] tub oh
my god that's got to be the worst when
you get so old you're afraid to take a
shower you got to bring like a [ __ ]
lazy boy in there oh [ __ ] I'm sorry
that just [ __ ] struck me it's funny
you just got a giant lazy butt you got a
recliner in your shower somehow it's
waterproof I don't know the [ __ ] you I
like I love that flashlight that just
came out that runs on water I mean give
me what are we doing what the [ __ ] are
we doing in the Middle East Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ just put that in a [ __ ]
car stick 2000 lights in the car I'll
Drive slower let's just get out of there
already alright looks like we think
we're doing you know what find the
Middle East it's like my lease is like
you're a civilian and you get in the
middle of like a domestic violence
[ __ ] incident you know and you try to
break it up you know in the second you
go to break it up the woman starts
beating on you I get off my abusive
husband that's what it's like over there
just [ __ ] get those water flashlights
this is what you do you get those water
flashlights and you put them into
[ __ ] scooters then everybody has to
ride a scooter whether you're fat or old
or whatever you got a ride one and cars
are illegal alright the amount of people
wipe it out dying right frees up the
[ __ ] traffic we're not used as much
oil and then they go bankrupt over there
how about that there did I solve the
Middle Eastern Promises don't do that
every week every week I'm gonna have a
new [ __ ] solution for the Middle East
anyway I don't want the [ __ ] I'm talking
about I just can you imagine us just
having a giant [ __ ] recliner you know
and then you have like that little
grabby thing and you just turn on the
[ __ ] water one of those grabby things
you know you [ __ ] you pull the handle
and you got a next
like the [ __ ] grocers they always
grab like a can of soup or some [ __ ]
what what do you want beef or broccoli
whatever they go up there they [ __ ]
yank it down I don't know if that
doesn't happen anymore there's no
there's no regular person running a
[ __ ] grocery store anymore reserved
grocery stores a [ __ ] weird man
no they kind of like the food version of
a casino like he just feel like there's
somebody up in the ceiling watching you
buying like a two-way mirror when you go
in there there's really nothing stop but
y'all know one time I walked to this
grocery store Patrice and we acted like
[ __ ] children
he got me going like he was so [ __ ]
silly I mean one time he just goes we
were going and he was staying at my
apartment for pilot season both of us
creeps trying to get on must-see TV yeah
how do you think that worked out so we
were in like Ralph's or some [ __ ] and he
just kept going it bill you want some of
these and when he would go to point at
it he would like key to have his hand
way too close to the big bag and he like
it was like bread or something he goes
bill you need some of this anyway he
just pushed his finger into like [ __ ]
three slices of bread through the
wrapper and he just started doing that
around the grocery store and I was
[ __ ] crying laughing you did it the
cookies he was doing he's doing it to
fruit and these giant [ __ ] fingers
hey Billy one of the easy just like all
the way through the [ __ ] thing and
I'm immature as [ __ ] and it was just
making me [ __ ] cry laughs and he's a
comedian so he just kept doing it and I
was trying to do it I could even feel my
fingers weren't I don't know I was
laughing to her I couldn't [ __ ] do it
as good as him
anyways Jesus ain't thought about that
for [ __ ] ever
and I want to apology it wasn't Ralph's
what the [ __ ] were we I always hated
where else you know just a [ __ ] pain
in the ass the one that was down the
street nice to live off a sunset and
there was a Ralph's used to be called
rock and roll Ralph's everything was
rock and roll Denny's rock and roll
Ralph steps back like left
from the hair metal [ __ ] you know the
rock-and-roll high it right next to
[ __ ] the Comedy Store John Bonham
used to ride motorcycles there's some
[ __ ] into the [ __ ] thing I don't know
what I have no idea and what the [ __ ] it
was I even know where we were at Jesus
Christ I haven't thought of that in
forever what the [ __ ] was I talking
about talking about being an old man
with a recliner and a goddamn shower
whatever that moment's come and gone
that's what happens on the podcast I
just [ __ ] talk and whatever happens
it happens by the way I would like to
thank everybody that came out to
Albuquerque New Mexico
I had a great [ __ ] time at route 66
casino I've that's the second time I
played there I [ __ ] love that place
the crowd was awesome and then the next
the next last night I played in Tucson
Arizona
another great town just [ __ ] great
people great parts of the country fun
[ __ ] crowds and I got to tell you I
am acting like a [ __ ] idiot on stage
like yet I think it's my reaction to
this [ __ ] this this weird fog that is
starting to roll in slowly rolling in
over the last five years on stand-up
comedy where all of a sudden I sit there
on stage and sometimes I think after I
say something like did somebody record
that am I gonna get into trouble I
haven't thought I never thought that the
first [ __ ] 20 years of my career in
the last five years it just keeps
creeping into my head and in order to
beat it down I I don't know I think I'm
going a little harder
somebody's got there's got to be some
sort of push back on this [ __ ] vibe
that's out there that everything is so
goddamn serious now jesus-fuckin'-christ
couple guys want to be women a couple
guys take their dicks out at work and
then all of a sudden everybody's got how
did he mean that joke is that a joke or
is that legislation for a new law like
this whole [ __ ] vibe that's out there
it's it's it's really weird and [ __ ]
young people are acting like old people
you know and I think that's because
they're on social media and all that
[ __ ] and they're just watching this
stuff 25
seven it's like [ __ ] I don't know
it's [ __ ] up their brains I mean come
on Millennials you got to do something
that's what you're supposed to make me
uncomfortable you know I guess they have
that new documentary meth town unfuckin
HBO D del Rey told me to watch that I
can't [ __ ] watch that [ __ ] I'm not
gonna watch a bunch of toothless [ __ ]
people those goddamn people I swear to
god they look like they're from the
1800s that's how bad they [ __ ] their
faces up with that meth [ __ ] I'll tell
you once you lose your [ __ ] teeth you
look like you're 80 I don't care how old
you are you could take one of those
gorgeous Victoria's Secret models if
they don't have any [ __ ] teeth and
they didn't get a partial or a [ __ ]
implant or whatever the [ __ ] you call
them dentures are some if you just walk
around toothless you immediately look
you look like Homer Simpson's [ __ ]
that guy that falls asleep is dad is it
his dad their grandfather right I don't
know yeah so I had that on I was talking
to someone on the phone and and Dean
kept telling me see what you got to see
it to it you got to see and even Dean
said man I [ __ ] shut this thing off
like three times he goes it's [ __ ]
brutal so I just had the sound down and
I was watching all these toothless
[ __ ] people with these crazed looks
on their faces and I was on the phone
and at one point I just saw somebody
kicking dog [ __ ] like piles of dog [ __ ]
different piles all around the house
like hoarding dog [ __ ] out of the way in
this person's house with newspaper all
over and stuff and that's when I turned
the channel I don't know about you guys
but I drew the line at the I drew the
line at the dog [ __ ] there's a few
things that make me turn the channel
okay drug addicts with dog [ __ ] in their
house and and strong female characters
make me turn the channel and not because
I have anything against a strong female
character it's just
they don't develop them I think
everybody in Hollywood is so afraid of
getting yelled at by these women's
groups that they just throw in these
strong female characters but they don't
they don't make a three-dimensional
character they just have a woman yelling
at guys and grabbing them by their
[ __ ] lapels of their suit and throw
them over couches and [ __ ] it's like
they took like leftover Steven Seagal
[ __ ] and the guy will give it to the
woman here see she's strong all of a
sudden every [ __ ] show just like with
this [ __ ] person sky outweighs their
by like a [ __ ] hundred pounds what am
i what am i watching I watched that
recently I might even say the [ __ ]
show but I'm watching this guy this
guy's like 40 [ __ ] years old he's
talking to a 19 year old redneck woman
who lives next to a [ __ ] lake in the
middle of Arkansas and she's having a
battle of wits with them and she's
winning Mike jesus [ __ ] christ the
[ __ ] what kind of a [ __ ] 19 year old
could beat a [ __ ] 50 year old guy in
a battle of wits what's it talking about
[ __ ] Nintendo whatever the [ __ ]
kids play in the 10th oh sorry whatever
you guys play I'm not a gamer all right
I used to be a boozehound I'm still not
drinking the [ __ ] is it it's one of my
hundred and some days and at this point
it's 105 days three days and that's 108
we 109 by the time you listen to this
thing but I got to tell you I'm [ __ ]
I'm getting a week I'm getting a week oh
the holidays are rolling in I think I'll
be good through December but uh I'm
going to the [ __ ] Rose Bowl again
this year this is my 10th Rose Bowl all
right it's the tenth anniversary for me
and Joe bartnik the originals the
original [ __ ] drunk maniacs at that
game and what's so [ __ ] awesome now
about the college football playoff is
that every three years now the Rose Bowl
is a playoff game last time it was
Florida State in Oregon I believe
Jamison Winston and the guy from [ __ ]
the Tennessee Tysons I can't remember
his name Mariota is that the
I don't want to [ __ ] the guy from Oregon
he's great right and this year it's
gonna be the Oklahoma Sooners versus the
[ __ ] who else got in let's see it's
Clemson versus Alabama and then we got
the [ __ ] Oklahoma's playing who
nobody in the big ten got in TCU got
their [ __ ] asses kicked okay whenever
I watched TCU they win I can't believe I
[ __ ] miss that who the [ __ ] is
Oklahoma play wasn't Wisconsin Clemson
is Alabama I gotta hit pause here this
is gonna now [ __ ] that you guys can
listen dumb I am I know this USC didn't
get in it's got to be a conference
[ __ ] champion Miami loss to Clemson
Auburn didn't get in who the [ __ ] is it
I gotta hit pause I don't know the [ __ ]
it is I'm an [ __ ] Georgia I actually
didn't look it up I just sat there and I
[ __ ] started think like what a [ __ ]
else is in there Miami Central Florida
Florida State South Carolina Gators
Georgia that's how I did it
started down I was stuck down in Miami
and I [ __ ] worked my way up the
Georgia Georgia Bulldogs and I know
there's a lot of people were upset a lot
of people were upset that it's such a
flawed [ __ ] system I know Jay lawhead
was telling me that [ __ ] Alabama
didn't play anybody it's like they
didn't [ __ ] play anybody and I'm
thinking like well the big ten wasn't
his [ __ ] you know Wisconsin being
undefeated is amazing until you [ __ ]
look at the you know the western side of
the [ __ ] Big Ten Nebraska stinks
Illinois was pathetic
Indiana steaks Minnesota steaks
northwestern was decent they were seven
and two but I mean if they won the last
seven games but they played nobody and I
was sitting there going like so I'm like
what the [ __ ] is he talking about
you know
it's like you guys lost a [ __ ] Iowa
Iowa's at was halfway decent Penn State
was overrated what the [ __ ] you talking
about so you know what I did I actually
listened to jail ahead and I looked up
the [ __ ] Alabama Crimson Tide's
[ __ ] schedule and I gotta tell you I
think I could have got them five [ __ ]
wins jail ahead sorry j-law had I owe an
apology to this is who they play Florida
State who stinks then they played
Colorado State I don't know what they
those [ __ ] people should be selling
insurance out there get rid of that
football team Mississippi they stink
this year Arkansas stunk this year LSU
and I only came on late but they stink I
love them Mar sir is that a woman's
college I didn't know the [ __ ] that is
Fresno State I went to that game Fresno
State you know I'd say they stink but
I've watched too many of those behind
the scenes things about Franco pool
carriers I'm not gonna say [ __ ] about
Fresno I'm just saying you know they
could have been a little better
Vanderbilt that too [ __ ] smart to be
good Texas A&M they stunk
Tennessee [ __ ] stinks Mississippi
State was decent then they played a burn
who was a good [ __ ] team and they lost
however they did beat the [ __ ] out of
people
they won 24-7 4123 66 to 341 the nine
they did beat the [ __ ] out of people 56
to nothing against the Woman's College
41 to 10 59 to nothing against
Vanderbilt no they played a bunch of
[ __ ] architects Nate bargatze was
starting at [ __ ] punter 27:19
against Texas A&M 45-7 hey by the way
all those students that [ __ ] that guy
out of that [ __ ] head coaching job at
Tennessee were those signs that they
wrote was that true I know cuz they
really [ __ ] I don't know man I hope
they did some research this whole
[ __ ] trial by Internet I left to look
that up man cuz that just that was like
[ __ ] and some of the [ __ ] that people
wrote on signs he was at Penn State I
don't know
during the whole time or part of the
time when that Sandusky guy was there
but it's just like you know it
I don't understand this I love how
there's like one guy does some [ __ ] then
all of a sudden like the most horrific
[ __ ] thing you could do basically and
then all of a sudden everybody [ __ ]
knew and nobody said anything
everybody everybody I'm not saying there
weren't a few people like oh Jesus we
got to [ __ ] protect the University
but just anybody who was there is
automatically [ __ ] guilty some of
these [ __ ] kids man I you know this
whole trial by [ __ ] social media is a
little out of control there but anyways
I'm going off the rails here so I don't
know we'll see we'll see what the [ __ ]
happens I know Jay was upset that Ohio
State didn't get in you gotta take Ohio
State had a tougher schedule than
[ __ ] Alabama easily easily had a
tougher [ __ ] schedule but what about
what about Auburn what about armor man
they beat Georgia when they were number
one then they beat Alabama then they'd
be too [ __ ] number once then they had
to go back and beat [ __ ] Georgia
again they couldn't do it you know what
happened with that
that [ __ ] Auburn's coach opened his
big fat [ __ ] mouth we kicked the dog
crap out him did with we don't kick the
dog crap out of them did with you know
what I mean I hope every [ __ ] person
who's in sports journalism
I hope they watch that they see that
[ __ ] clip and then you see the
[ __ ] Georgia Bulldogs showing up the
next game with flames coming out of
their [ __ ] nostrils you know the next
time you're gonna sit there and trash
Bill Belichick and say he's
quote-unquote was so boring and his
press conferences that's because the man
is a genius
Bill Belichick is never gonna be like
what kicked the dog grandpa what doesn't
work why the [ __ ] would just say that
you know it says that the kind of guy
who wears a [ __ ] golf and hat when
he's coaching a football team what a
dumb [ __ ] thing that then is the
stupidest [ __ ] thing you can do
remember when the [ __ ] Cowboys will
[ __ ] kick in the [ __ ] out of the
steelers and like superbowl 9 or 10 I
don't
about 40 years ago you have a look at
those highlights and [ __ ] roid Joella
missed that field goal and stupid ass
cliff Harris got in his face patted him
on the [ __ ] helmet and then Lambert
came over and just body slam cliff
Harris back when you could do that and
it wasn't [ __ ] you know a bunch of
fines and you had to go [ __ ] sing
acapella to some [ __ ] a woman's group
whatever the [ __ ] punishment is now
right you could do that that turned the
tide of the game keep your [ __ ] mouth
shut
until you holding the championship
trophy and then you don't need to talk
[ __ ] cause you want it you're [ __ ]
what happens you play him a few weeks
later you get the L right there Fred
don't you so anyways there was a lot of
uh there was a lot of uh I was on a
percent wrong I thought j-law head was
just being a [ __ ] homer he was
absolutely [ __ ] right Alabama didn't
play anybody but they scored a lot of
[ __ ] points who knows we'll see well
say now if Alabama goes in and wins the
whole [ __ ] thing then what does that
do I actually like how vague this is and
how many arguments that it creates just
a whole [ __ ] you know and at the end of
the day you can't you can't open this up
to some giant [ __ ] March Madness the
game is just simply too [ __ ] violent
I love that it's four teams and I love
that people get left out you know the
same way I love seeing a little kid
crying because his mother wouldn't get
him the toy that he wanted that just
warms my heart whenever I see that I
hate seeing little spoiled brats like a
[ __ ] you I gave you Cheerios this
morning didn't you didn't I you know
meanwhile I'm gonna spoil this [ __ ] out
of my daughter I'm all over the map here
and what the [ __ ] I'm talking about so
that's what I did all day all day on
Friday Friday and Saturday I just
watched [ __ ] college football other
than when I was traveling going out to
the [ __ ] did I fly out to Albuquerque
New Mexico it was funny there was a six
hour drive from Albuquerque to
son I should have done that I wasn't
paying attention I actually flew down
and rather than getting a direct flight
I had to connect through Phoenix so it
was the fight I could have flown from LA
to the goddamn Columbus Ohio you know
and speaking of Buckeyes right and that
the amount of time that took me and this
the [ __ ] person who flew us from
Phoenix from from Albuquerque to Phoenix
okay we're taxiing out to get to the I
don't know on our way out to the runway
right and the guy bangs a left
and then quickly goes back to the right
and I was just like whoa what the [ __ ]
and I was like why you know maybe it was
the tower maybe they said make a left on
Bravo or I mean right sorry right
correction go right on Bravo right so I
got this app where I can listen to the
tower so I put it onto here try and
listen to see if I could hear anything
which I couldn't so we take off flights
great flying everything's fine not no
[ __ ] problems you come in got land
land landing was nice and everything and
then we're going in
but taxing again we going to get into
the where you parked the plane whatever
the [ __ ] you call that the gate and this
[ __ ] guy he literally did a donut he
did a 360 with the airplane he once
again went left when he was supposed to
go right and we [ __ ] did an entire
three not a maybe not an entire 360 I
think he just missed the game he just
drove by it and then he couldn't go
right into it cuz he would have hit the
other plane so he had to because it was
on the right-hand side he had a bang the
left and we look it did like a [ __ ]
donut everybody's in the plane like what
the [ __ ] are we doing guy had a bad day
he or she whoever the [ __ ] was up front
it was hilarious
everybody was getting off the plane like
- what the [ __ ] was that the hell just
happened - yeah you know what happens
you know you drive down the street
sometimes you missed the Home Depot like
that [ __ ] I got to go back around again
I don't feel like doing it legally and
you just [ __ ] bang aue right well the
same thing happens in aviation evidently
ever [ __ ] deadly the same thing
happens Jesus what the [ __ ] is going on
in Kansas City by the way they lost to
the New York Jets
Jetts a decent good lord
this is why you know coaching in the NFL
has got to be a [ __ ] can you imagine
Andy Reid after September starts the
year they [ __ ] beat the dog that the
thing we beat the dog crap out of them
[ __ ] Patriots no way right not really
they just dominated the fourth quarter
and ran away with it at that point right
everybody's all excited holy [ __ ] all of
a sudden Tom Brady's [ __ ] old and the
[ __ ] water goes down the drain the
different way black is white white he's
black you don't know what the [ __ ]
going on all the way through September I
bet he started to build an addition unto
his [ __ ] house you know getting ready
to put that [ __ ] trophy in there and
after these last two [ __ ] months the
last eight goddamn weeks I would say
that that they've stopped the
construction he probably has a tarp over
the top of it I like Andy Reid I hope
they turn it around I haven't been able
to watch the game but jesus [ __ ]
christ they can't get a goddamn win they
cannot get a [ __ ] win so I actually
watched a bunch of football today too
when I when I landed I watched the
Patriots first the bills I thought that
was gonna be a lot closer game I thought
Tyrod Taylor was gonna give us headaches
alright
Tyrod Taylor I like that guy but I'll
tell you right now he is no Russell
Wilson and after watching the [ __ ]
Seattle Seahawks tonight I'm gonna go
out on a limb I think I could block for
Russell Wilson I could just have a guy
in about eight seconds run around me and
then just watch him [ __ ] be like this
modern-day Fran Tarkenton that guy is
[ __ ] unbelievable I don't even know
how good
Seattle's offensive line is I don't even
know if they're decent all I know is at
the end of every game they should be
giving they should be [ __ ] making it
rained Russell Wilson's locker because
they're all going to get a big contract
because I guarantee you he probably got
sacked probably I don't know what three
times four times less than he should
have the [ __ ] Eagles were in the
backfield it was like every time he went
back for the pass the guy to run that
guy next to 40 yards until somebody got
opened
the guys are like I don't like I felt
like they got it maybe two or three
times that game
maybe but Jesus Christ as that guy fun
to watch and Seattle locals say look
[ __ ] and they look really strong man I
was actually kind of like rooting for
the Eagles cuz uh you know I don't know
what the Patriots gonna do I you never
know when you're playing the AFC East
you know that's our [ __ ] schedules
like the Alabama Crimson Tide you don't
dolphin stink Bills stink that Jets
stink this year they're all [ __ ]
average you know I mean there's
literally six wins right there so I'd
really don't know how good we are but
that was a huge game tonight
this always feels like a sports podcast
I did start off talking about [ __ ]
old people and lazy boys right tonight
and I also believe I solved the Middle
Eastern crisis
I just watched ops I just watched a ton
of [ __ ] football and well at this
point you gotta be the football if
you're still listening so I'm not gonna
apologize I should apologize like
[ __ ] ten minutes ago but I don't know
that defense look [ __ ] great Richard
Sherman isn't even in there can I ask
you guys a [ __ ] question about the
Achilles tendon why why do you rupture
your Achilles tendon but you tear your
ACL why is that why don't you rupture
your ACL and tear your [ __ ] Achilles
tendon why is that is it because your
Achilles tendon goes up your [ __ ] back
your leg like a [ __ ] window shade is
that what it is you know I'm actually
gonna look that up I'm gonna look that
up I'm gonna put this [ __ ] urban myth
this just is it a myth bill no it's not
it's a I don't know it's a [ __ ]
question I have why do you rupture
that's not gonna come out right your
Achilles okay wait you know because
they'll be like cuz you [ __ ] didn't
stretch that's the wrong way to search
how about rupture verse tear Achilles
all right let's see what we got here
what do we got here
achilles tendon rupture is an injury
that affects the back of your lower leg
oh is that where it is Jesus Christ all
right
it mainly occurs in people playing
recreational sports that means white
guys playing pick-up hoop every [ __ ]
white dude I know over the age of 40 35
40 who still plays hoops every one of
them gets the kobe injury but it can
happen to anyone that's why before you
get out of bed if you're a [ __ ] old
person especially an old white guy all
right I don't know I mean the main black
guys other than [ __ ] Richard Sherman
and Kobe Bryant like superstar black
guys do it right but average white
people just all the [ __ ] time I'm
just making up [ __ ] here before you get
out of bed in the morning I'm telling
you if you run a little tight okay I'm
telling you I've said this before you
[ __ ] take your toes point them at
your knees slowly all right and if you
get it if you get a [ __ ] charley
horse in your [ __ ] calves immediately
point your toes in the other direction a
little release okay but if you don't
just point you in your [ __ ] do it
right now your desk what the [ __ ] you're
not doing [ __ ] right but you sit down
right don't do it wait till your [ __ ]
laying down don't listen to me but I'm
still gonna talk here right
point your toes at your knees and you
need caps that's all you do and you just
do that for a good I don't know 15 20
seconds right then you pointed in the
other direction at the [ __ ] wall or
whatever is in front of you all right
your dog that's laying on the end of
your bed okay then once you do that for
15 seconds then you roll your [ __ ]
feet clockwise a couple times then
counterclockwise then you get out of bed
don't just lay there for [ __ ] eight
hours sleeping with you goddamn apnea
and then just pop out of bed and take
that first step because you're gonna get
you get you gonna be [ __ ] plant a fish
or write us all that [ __ ] all right
let's let's continue the Achilles tendon
is a strong fibrous cord that connects
the muscles in the back of your calf to
your heel bone if you over stretch your
Achilles tendon it can tear [ __ ] wait a
minute I thought it's because you didn't
tear slash rupture completely or just
partially if your Achilles tendon
Cheers you might hear a pop followed by
an immediate [ __ ] like scream that
appears to come from your mouth area now
followed by an immediate sharp pain in
the back of your ankle and lower leg
that is likely to affect your ability to
walk properly surgery is often performed
to repair the rupture for many people
however non-surgical treatment works
just as well this is not answering my
[ __ ] question
why do they say rupture for Achilles I
can't believe I know how to spell
Achilles
it's how big a [ __ ] Zeppelin fan I am
I spelt it wrong Achilles tendon rupture
shows you what to do if you take you
know what I don't even give a [ __ ]
anymore somebody's got to be a goddamned
doctor or a first responder we could
[ __ ] tell me what it means all right
let me be a little advertising here for
the week ah zip recruiter everybody
ladies and gentlemen it's all zip with
zip recruiter you could post your job to
over 100 web's leading job boards with
just one click so you can rest easy
knowing your job is being seen by the
right candidates then all's it puts it's
smart matching technology to work
actively notifying qualified candidates
about your job within minutes of posting
so you can receive the best possible
mass matches
no wonder 80% of employees who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day even
pimps advertise on this and the
easy-to-use dashboard lets you manage
your hiring process from start to finish
all in one place it the smartest way to
hire find out today why zip recruit has
been used by growing businesses of all
sizes and industries to find out the
most qualified job candidates with
immediate results
right now my listeners can post on old
zip for free that's right free just go
to zip recruiters calm / / that zip
criticized for it one more time for free
go to zip / / alright oh look who's here
everybody uh but don't do me andhis me
undies what's going on in Kansas City to
do me undies me undies Andy Reid's got
sweaty titties he shoulda put that [ __ ]
on the side of his house he's gonna get
fired and they'll hire a [ __ ] louse
cuz that's what Kansas City does they
torture their fans what the [ __ ]
happened in Super Bowl dreams me undies
anyway everybody let me tell you about
me undies it's the only underwear that
makes for an amazing gift soft flexible
waistband three times softer than cotton
naturally sustainable sourced fiber me
undies made underwear the perfect gift
that everyone is going to love for you
it's a god damn holiday miracle you
[ __ ] bastard this year don't give
underwear
give me undies this holiday season by
Dubi Dubi it's the holiday season you
want soft [ __ ] up against your nuts not
literally frequent medaled matter I
can't [ __ ] sing this holiday season
dooby dooby doo to get your exclusive
20% off the softest underwear and socks
you will ever wear free shipping and
100% satisfaction to guarantee go to the
undies com / bar that's me undies
dot-com / / how many [ __ ] more do we
got here Dollar Shave Club everybody if
you want to shave your balls or just
look like you have shape balls just use
Dollar Shave Club just like their razors
everything is super high-quality and
won't have you looking and feeling
amazing shave your nuts get some [ __ ]
me undies and then [ __ ] find somebody
to lick your balls on zip recruiter you
like how I'm tying it all together and
then when you go to court mail something
through stamp com from premium
ingredients to sophisticated sense
Dollar Shave Club is changing the game
if you're sick of the nonsense at the
store
now's the time to try out Dollar Shave
Club for a limited time Dollar Shave
Club is basically giving away their [ __ ]
shower shave starter set to new members
for only $5 this starter set features
their executive razor and three trial
size versions of their most popular
products that help you stay fresh and
clean in your first box you will receive
their shaved body wash and one wipe
Charlies butt wipes
speaking of Charlie I watched Ken Burns
the end of that is [ __ ] thing on the
Vietnam War it's incredible but anyways
you will also receive their executive he
Sur which includes their premium weighty
handle and focused set of cartridges and
the first box replacement cartridges are
sent for only a few bucks a month this
offer is exclusively available at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / and if you want
a great gift give him Dollar Shave Club
I just said this [ __ ] thank God they've
got super simple gift memberships and II
give cards Dollar Shave club's high
quality products will have you covered
from face cheeks to butt cheeks there's
no better time to try the club you know
it's cool isn't that Ken Burns the war
they had a North Vietnamese soldier I
swear to God his first name was boo and
he wrote a book about his experiences
and I got to read that [ __ ] thing it's
always great to hear what the other side
was thinking you know I mean it
humanizes him but they have [ __ ]
scared they miss their family you know
what I mean it's good wow that never
works in sports you go to somebody
else's stadium he's still like I don't
like these [ __ ] cuts
alright stamps calm everybody
wow they cut off all the copy it just
starts with so do what I do use stamps
calm instead I've done this coffee
enough I can memorize hey everybody this
holiday season dooby-dooby-doo don't go
to the post-office stand behind all
those old people that took a shower with
sitting in a [ __ ] lazy boy you know
you're gonna be there they can have all
kinds of [ __ ] questions you're not
gonna know what to do right [ __ ] all in
that [ __ ] would it be great if you just
do it from your own house wouldn't it be
wonderful
would be grave you just do everything
from your house that's a different story
all right do what I do go to you
stamps.com instead stamps.com brings all
the services of the US Post Office right
into your goddamn house via print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer you're bringing the
post office into your house rednecks
with guns relax it's not literally a
stranger in your house okay
it's just figuratively speaking
figuratively speaking put your goddamn
gun down
then the mailman picks it up don't shoot
him stamps calms makes it easy they'll
send you a digital scale automatically
calculates exact postage stamp stock rom
will even help you decide out of the
[ __ ] blue the best class of mail
every time print postage any day any
time stance calm is always open I use
stamps calm anytime I send out my
[ __ ] posters and I want to get
sexually assaulted by drunk Cougars at
the end of the [ __ ] show and right
now you two can enjoy the stamps.com
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
and digital scale without long term
commitments go to stamps a common type
in birth be URR that stamp stock
commenter burrow I write mercifully that
is [ __ ] over
alright thirty-eight [ __ ] minutes in
here then I talk about everything I
wanted to talk about our date a night
then I do die oh you know what I ordered
this old Modern Drummer because it was
right around the time John Bonham died
they had this little John Bonham
retrospective I thought they're gonna be
a little more shocked that he was gone
they just kind of said you know he's one
of the great drummers of all time he has
all his beats and all that [ __ ] you know
it's real it's really cool one like
what's-his-face is on the cover let me
see who's on that I don't know who's on
the cover it's so long ago it's 1981
hang on a sec oh [ __ ] it's Peter Chris
Peter Criss and he's sitting I swear to
God he is playing a pearl drum kit with
concert toms that you novices out there
that means there's no bottom heads if
you ever watched Phil Collins that's
what he get right and her still has he
has a kick and a snare and then he has
one two three four five six seven rack
toms and two floor toms so he has an 11
piece kit to play I wanna rock n roll
all night and party every day before
hours later I buttered identify data but
it ass crash that's what I like about
these old [ __ ] these that [ __ ] kit is
the [ __ ] and then they got like back
then they had all of these they got
these [ __ ] drum kits do you guys
remember when they'd have the on the
bass drum they'd have the they mount to
Tom's and then they'd have a third one
there when I opened this up ludwig
they've always had the inside front
cover
they actually this guy from REO
Speedwagon alan Gratzer he has four
[ __ ] toms how the [ __ ] could you even
reach those ones up top unbelievable
anyways I love looking at this [ __ ] you
look at like the bass drum pedals that
they had and this was like the 80s this
was like 15 years after John Bonham did
good times bad times so I can't I mean I
don't use like the Ludwig
speaking look at Peter Chris's kid
[ __ ] British racing green
he looks good man he looks good without
the makeup back in 1981 anyways I don't
know I'm gonna do that old [ __ ] I'm
sorry I don't know what the [ __ ] I
brought that up
I just wanted to bore you guys to tear
alright tears alright key 41 minutes and
I can start reading it God knows the way
I [ __ ] read does anybody know how you
[ __ ] you remember your iCloud
password or your Instagram password
I just [ __ ] I just once I lose them
and then I just I can't like I can't get
into my own house
alright girlfriends friends boyfriend
demands an apology girlfriends friends
boyfriend all right
so you have a girlfriend who has a
friend it was a boyfriend and they want
an apology from you dear Burbank bad boy
brain Red Bird red bar whatever the [ __ ]
that means
bill Burbank that's gonna be my [ __ ]
alias I've got an interesting one for
you a little bit of context I am twenty
four and two years out of school I live
with my girlfriend of almost five years
roughly two years ago on a sorority trip
with my girlfriend her friend and her
friend's boyfriend I gave the girl one
of those awkward side hugs after she
went out for a beer run no sexual intent
whatsoever just to thank you evidently
the boyfriend felt otherwise and flew
into a rage shortly thereafter insulting
the girl and my girlfriend I didn't
learn about this until well after and
since I have no relationship with the
guy was content to let it be now wait a
minute
did the guy see the side hug all right
wait what the [ __ ] happened I gave the
girl of one of the one of those awkward
side hugs after she went out for a beer
run no sexual intent whatever just to
thank you evidently the boyfriend felt
otherwise it flew into a rage shortly
after I guess he waited to you leave
well this guy's a [ __ ] that what are
you worried about he was [ __ ] there
what'd she call him up he [ __ ]
touched this opposite side shoulder of
mine all right flash florid for two
years later the two of them have just
gotten engaged my girlfriend will be a
bridesmaid and learn from the other girl
I will not be invited to the wedding
unless I apologize to the boyfriend now
go
[ __ ] yourself [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ]
why doesn't he call you up good wedding
that you apologize to me why is this
woman marrying this guy two years later
he's still mad about a side hug Jesus
Christ how possessive is this [ __ ]
maniac I feel bad for the woman that's
marrying this lunatic all right for
inappropriately touching his girl well
dude by the way I'm just hearing your
side of the story you know did you do
one of those awkward side hugs and then
jehanne came off her shoulder it
accidentally went across her ass if it
was just an awkward side hug I say [ __ ]
this guy out of respect for my
girlfriend I'm tempted to apologize but
since an apology is a mission of guilt
and I didn't do anything wrong my pride
is holding me back you know what because
you just said that I actually believe in
you I should believe you I'm surprised
that he's been too cowardly to approach
me and is having to work through two
people to get what he wants what would
you do you know what I would do I would
I would go [ __ ] find out what Sports
is playing in that area tell my
girlfriend to have a good time at the
[ __ ] wedding love the podcast love to
stand up Thanks
this is what I would say I would just
say I did nothing wrong so I'm not
apologizing and tell that groom to be
congratulations on getting married and
at some point he might want to grow a
dick if he wants to be the man of the
house I'll get some [ __ ] balls dude
[ __ ] that guy if I would go to a [ __ ]
tractor pull before I go to that [ __ ]
wedding oh Jesus Christ
you know be [ __ ] hilarious go to the
wedding anyways and then after they
[ __ ] exchange their goddamn vows go
up and give her a side hug yeah dude
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that I don't feel like I
don't see your letter that there's any
pressure from your now girlfriend you
know however if you don't go she you
know she might be what the fact they've
been going out less than us and they're
getting married really it flex my ring
you might have to go down that road but
I got to tell you this might be a twofer
you've already you've been dating this
woman for five [ __ ] years you're not
giving her a ring so what the
I say you dump your current girlfriend
and tell that guy to go [ __ ] himself and
you know I dump everybody in this
[ __ ] story sorry I'm a little grumpy
don't listen to me but I definitely
wouldn't apologize that gun I would go
to the wedding you're a guy who the [ __ ]
wants to go to a wedding this is great
you got an out all right and just stay
with that I just can't do it because I
feel it's an admission of guilt and
during this sensitive time this climate
I'm worried that did this if I if I say
I'm sorry then this was somehow going to
my Instagram which is tied to my
facebook and over to my Twitter and I
might not get a job just call that
[ __ ] room or you could just be a man
and just say I'm not apologizing that
guy [ __ ] him all right and then you your
[ __ ] girlfriend I would love to go
but I'm not going under those
circumstances and I'll tell you right
now if you didn't do [ __ ] and the
[ __ ] bride wanted you apologize and
you didn't want to I would back you so
I'm not going if you want to go you can
go if you're not going get over here and
blow me and let's go to the game there
you go that's what you say all right
boyfriend rides motocross dear bill I
love all your work in your comedy thank
you you're so inspiring
Jesus Christ here buddy but do okay
where died like where I'd like your
input here we go I'm seriously dating
someone who loves to ride in race
motocross that's [ __ ] awesome I bet I
bet this isn't the same woman from the
last one you know I bet this isn't the
guy that's getting married the motocross
guy this guy's [ __ ] cool this guy
doesn't like a [ __ ] side hug he's
just gonna [ __ ] punch you in the face
with his motorcycle gloves still on
right we've been together for over a
year so I'm starting to think about
marriage and a family with this person
because we're both 25 that's that makes
sense he's awesome in every way and the
person I know I want to be with forever
well there you go
but he loves to ride and race motocross
it's not on the professional level it's
a hobby Oh sweetheart you're gonna do
this - you're gonna take away his
[ __ ] hobby we got to talk recently
when I asked him how long he wants to
keep riding and he said for
I know someone who has two children who
husband had an accident riding a dirt
bike he's paralyzed and doesn't remember
who his kids are well Jesus Christ
there's people who get in cars I mean
come on man what are you doing this is
come on I'll tell you right now if you
if this guy who you want to marry if you
want to make him [ __ ] miserable
after explaining this to my boyfriend he
said if something's going to happen to
me it will whether I'm riding motocross
or not I'm not going to change what I
love doing because of fear of what could
happen I got to tell you this I I
understand why you love this guy I'm
starting to develop feelings for this
guy he's holding this ground he's riding
motorcycles I mean you date the [ __ ]
Marlboro Man here I think I think that's
a selfish response when it involves your
children I hate to trying well you don't
have any kids yet all right you said I
hate to try to convince him to stop
something he loves doing so much but I
can't imagine being with someone who
participates in an extreme sport as a
hobby when I have children with them is
it wrong of me to ask him to promise to
stop and we have kids or am I being
controlling well first of all the fact
that you asked that you're a cool person
all right if you're actually questioning
your behavior this is the thing I think
you're a little further ahead
emotionally in this relationship than
when he's at where most women are all
right
and this is the thing when you become a
dad you do change all right so that
rather than [ __ ] nag him about this
[ __ ] just let the guy ride and if you
get married okay I'm telling you right
now
when you get married and you have a
[ __ ] kid this guy is gonna be so
[ __ ] sleep-deprived and so goddamn
tired he's not gonna have time to ride
okay though as much as he used to which
will then make it safer because he's not
riding as much but I think there's a big
thing you can't when you love somebody
you have to let them do what they love
unless it's heroin
okay or being a pedophile obvious
[ __ ] things all right but other you
know if my wife like all of a sudden
wanted to be one of those roller derby
queens as much as it would [ __ ]
destroy me watching her taking those
bumps as the elbow and him as ice
skating around if she really loved doing
it you know I wouldn't tell her not to
[ __ ] do it I really would be worried
about concussions and [ __ ] like that I
would be I'm not gonna lie to you but
you got to let people do what they do it
sounds like you got a really cool guy
that you're dating by the way so
congratulations and I think you're gonna
be a great mom
because you're doing what a mom does a
moms already looking way into the future
trying to figure out where the danger is
and try to eliminate it alright so I
think you're both lucky to have each
other just [ __ ] relax get yourself a
goddamn glass of wine let the guy ride
his bike you know you guys get married
someday I'm telling you when you get
[ __ ] knocked up and all of a sudden
he's got to go to 7-eleven you know cuz
you want beef jerky and a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't know and it's some
goddamn ice cream whatever you're
craving is you know believe me like I I
have had to make adjustments in my life
I think you'll be fine but you
definitely really you know you know they
would say a good man's hard to find a
good woman is also hard to find and the
fact that you're cool enough to actually
be considering am I being a douche here
I think you guys are gonna be alright
alright there you go alright named
neighbor invasion dear Billy mango tits
I don't know what that means it's
bizarre and I like it
alright I am an older lady who just
moved into a sweet cottage in the
boondocks last month alright I met my
next-door neighbor before I moved in and
I liked her instantly as she seemed warm
and funny as it turned out she's a
Kramer in the first week she came
knocking on my door numerous times for
social calls oh no and she will stay for
long periods of time
if I tell her I'm busy and she won't sit
down so I feel like a captive audience
to her monologues I'm a solitary person
and I don't like peeping people coming
over unannounced unless it's an
emergency this ain't this ain't Little
House on the Prairie I have told her
firmly on numerous occasions to [ __ ]
stop it oh good for you you're a strong
person I like it and I would appreciate
her emailing me and waiting for a
response or leaving a note if she wants
to hang out I'm not sure how much more
clearer I can be that I am uncomfortable
the situation especially when I see her
face and my kitchen window at night
waving me down it scares the [ __ ] out of
me
yeah that made me uncomfortable she's
even knocked on my bathroom window when
I didn't answer the door I don't wish to
be mean oh no you got to be mean you
have to be mean since I lived next to
her I know she's lonely and well yeah
cuz she's a [ __ ] lunatic what kind of
Guinea went that's look what she's doing
to you and you don't even live with
there can you imagine living with this
woman she'd be like that thing an alien
that's on those [ __ ] peoples faces I
know she is lonely in it and I'd like to
be friends with her but she but she just
no comprendo love your podcast and
advice and thanks your ginger moose
knuckle for not being a sex offender
because all my heroes are going down
well you know it's still early in this
game you know someone could accuse me of
something god knows it doesn't matter
what the [ __ ] I be another nobody really
innocent nobody who seemed innocent has
[ __ ] seemed have been called out yet
you know there's a couple people then
like I've never met that one of my life
and then it [ __ ] goes away so I think
it's alright right it still makes you
nervous as a guy going Jesus Christ
you know this whole trial by social
media is kind of scary over there
alright let's stay with the the topic
here I don't I don't know what I hope
just look all like I can't tell you what
to do all I can tell you is what I would
do all right I would do what you already
did
and all right you want to know what I
would do when she knocks on the door I'd
be like get out of here
[ __ ] off I would do that and when she
knocked on my window and scared the [ __ ]
out of me I'll be like Doody you wanna
[ __ ] mind he's scaring the [ __ ] out
of me I want to be friends with you but
you suffocate me you [ __ ] all right
do you want to be friends with me yes or
no yes great then stop being a [ __ ]
jerk-off stop knocking on my [ __ ]
dollar my window stop crying
all right make some lemonade she's one
of those people I don't know I I don't
know what I don't know what I would I
get a BB gun maybe shoot her in the
[ __ ] knee she comes over maybe she'll
think it's a beehive or some [ __ ] I
don't know what I would do I don't know
what the [ __ ] I would do if you've
actually told her that she sounds like a
crazy person why would you want to be
friends with a crazy person I think he
just got it you just got to ignore like
the next time she knocks on her when you
window like that I would just knock back
on the same on the other side of the
window I'd knock back and then give her
the finger see how she handles that
that's one way to do it the other way to
do it is to start talking about [ __ ]
that freaks her out if she's really
religious just talk about how much you
love Satan and you've given yourself
over to him I don't know what else you
could do partner presents I don't know I
have no idea I don't know what to do I
feel bad for you for some reason it
reminded me of misery I just keep
picturing that woman walking up to you
window the cockadoody whatever [ __ ]
come every window it's very American
Horror Story wife cries at least I hope
that helps you out I would just be more
firm writer a letter dear neighbor [ __ ]
off
sincerely
solitary woman in college cottage next
to you Frank
alright wife cries at least three times
a week dear Bilbo Baggins a big fan of
you of your fu attitude towards life I
don't have a [ __ ] you attitude towards
life okay I think it's very precious and
know that I am taking notes by telling
people to go [ __ ] yourself alright
anyways anyways I have an issue with my
wife-to-be because she cries all the
time
all right that's a deal-breaker for me
re already had my advice next time she
cries just gently put your hands on on
her shoulders maybe I could honey honey
grow up
now you get to write we've known each
other since January 2017 and our
marriage was arranged not forced but
arranged all right this is like tear and
rupture what the [ __ ] does that mean we
both chose to marry each other after our
parents allowed us to talk on the phone
for a few months what the [ __ ] is this
what what in what in God I didn't allow
you to talk on the [ __ ] phone the
first time you poke your head out of the
ground yeah you're gonna you're gonna
marry whatever you do just get away from
those controlling maniacs anyways since
we've been together and she's cried more
times than I've cried in my life
including the times I've cried during my
childhood everything she's crying
because she doesn't wanna marry you
that's what I'd be worried about she
cries for various different reasons like
her little sister annoys her feels like
she's lucky to have me feels like her
parents don't value her or she feels
like she won't do me proud as a wife oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
I don't even know what to do with this
person but you know that you seem like
you're from a different part of the
world at different cultures so but you
you do seem to know it but oh my god gee
[ __ ] Christ I think I would start
crying I just say if you don't stop
[ __ ] crying I swear to god I'm gonna
kill myself and that would make her cry
even more I'd just be like what do I
have to do okay
anyways we are definitely getting
married as that line has been crossed so
cutting it off isn't a possibility dude
where the [ __ ] are you in the world I
love her more than you love the freckles
on your face but but this is crying is
wearing me down well it seems like you
still have a sense of humor about it as
I have to comfort her every time and
just stare at her on FaceTime as she
cries at times it just gets super
annoying because she does cry over small
[ __ ] I gotta tell you something I don't
know this woman and she's already she's
annoying the [ __ ] out of me anyway she
has a busy schedule because she's
training to be a teacher oh god I hope
she doesn't [ __ ] teach some
underprivileged kids she'll have a
goddamn nervous breakdown second she
starts crying and shows weakness it's
going to be over anyways getting a
post-grad organising Islamic events
parenthesis no Isis jokes please and she
does an Islamic course at night
so I understand that she has [ __ ] loads
on her plate she's under confident and
she feels like she's not the model woman
you see on Instagram although I assure
her that she is beautiful and I loved
her just the way she is I really don't
know how to deal with this or even
approach the situation sometimes I find
that I am avoiding her because I know
Ali will leads are crying than what you
have you what do you suggest your
podcast is sex to my ears Nia is awesome
and I hope Lola is not giving Nia too
many sleepless nights thank you for
listening
old bright bulb begged Billie
jesus [ __ ] christ jesus [ __ ]
christ
III don't know what to tell you dude I
really I really don't know what the [ __ ]
to tell you I I don't know how to solve
this this is like how do you tell a
woman to stop crying in a way that
doesn't make him cry more all right
okay you know what I do when my wife is
gonna cry and I don't think it's that
big a deal and or I just don't want to
deal with it when she starts to cry I
just look at her and I jut out my bottom
lip and I make the saddest most pathetic
look just picture like a sad clown I
make the saddest stupid face
stupidest face and I look down while
still looking up at her just imagine
that look and it always makes her laugh
and she gets [ __ ] mad at me because
she can't continue crying because I look
so [ __ ] ridiculous and another way
you could do it is right before you make
that face you take a big inhale you go I
mean you just make that face and I'm
telling you if you if she has a sense of
[ __ ] humor that's what I would do I
think that's what I would do I would
just joke my way out of it anytime she
was crying over nothing I would start
crying with her like I just don't feel
that I'm gonna be good enough husband
for you and be like I would just be like
[Music]
now you have to know this I am a dick
all right but that's what I would do I
would just start doing that and what's
gonna happen is hopefully she'll toughen
up a little bit
Jesus Christ do you know how [ __ ]
nervous that would make me if a woman
was crying because she loves me that
much and was worried that she would be a
good [ __ ] I I would break up with her
I'd be like I can't handle that pressure
Jesus grip what what is gonna happen
when she finds out I can't [ __ ] read
out loud
mom's comment on pizza good luck to you
sir that's what I would do I would use
humor I would use humor you know next
time she go honey can I talk to you
about something I would have like 40
[ __ ] boxes of Kleenex and just
[ __ ] run over with like five boxes of
Kleenex er so I would just do something
to make it silly and ridiculous and then
she might get upset that you do that I
guess I would then say the [ __ ] would I
say I would just be honest just say
listen I I I love you to death but you
to let the amount that you cry I don't
know how to deal with it
[ __ ] that made you cry Jesus Christ what
do you guys so what do you Islamic guys
say when you curse what do you what'd
you say instead of Jesus Christ
what are you woody what do you say umm
do you say something you take do you
take Muhammad's name in vain do you do
something like that I with the whatever
the [ __ ] it is you say I I would I would
be really that would really fine I mean
that's a lot these [ __ ] letters are a
lot this week
okay the [ __ ] neighbor the goddamn
[ __ ] douchebag who needs an apology
for a [ __ ] side hug through two
different women he needs to get his
apology that guy is such a [ __ ] what
kind of a [ __ ] guy uninvite psin
other-- guy to a [ __ ] wedding is if
that's some sort of punishment he just
made his day you [ __ ] if you really
didn't like the side hug you should make
him [ __ ] go there and then there's
the one cool chick who [ __ ] boyfriend
rides motocross alright not saying the
other people weren't cool but good lord
wife cries at least three times a week I
read that as three times a day three
times a week that's still a lot it's a
hundred fifty six times a year
that's what I would do all right 365
minus 156 oh Jesus
256 250 that's 194 194 days you're not
crying
156 you are okay
that's like Marty Schottenheimer 's
lifetime record that like that's the way
you're crying days you cry verses days
you don't and that's not enough to make
in this league okay so I'm gonna need
you to toughen it up at least two-thirds
more why don't you tell us she's allowed
to cry once a week unless something
really bad happens okay you know you
could go to the pet store get one though
shocker collar and every time she starts
to cry just [ __ ] zapper I don't know
I don't know what to tell you right
mom's comment on pizza leads to breakup
I have no idea where this is going all
right hey Bill
weekly listener here love f is for
family and all your stand-up stuff keep
up the good work my question is what
experiences a Mia oh good to see you
come on in come on in Annie at this guys
[ __ ] wife Christ three times a week
it's hilarious did you guys hear that
she goes why are you gonna cry she cries
because she loves him so much she just
did a spit-take
I said well this is the thing that their
their Islamic and their parents allowed
them listen exactly I was telling them
what I do when you cry member that time
when you would cry and I just kept
making that face I go was not helpful by
the way
it helped me because I just didn't want
to deal I tell you something job isn't
to like check out and figure out a way
for you to deal with it your job is to
like check in and figure out I can deal
with it
your job is to make me feel better not
cope for yourself god yeah but sometimes
you just don't want to deal with like
like me you know when I you know when I
occasionally [ __ ] do be a nice person
be emotionally open don't be a [ __ ]
vast wasteland of non emotion man are
you high
yes you are okay
nobody cries she's lying cuz she's not
crying that much cuz she loves him say
something do you know like do you know
occasionally I'll get upset and I go on
a rant yeah would it be great if he knew
how to see what your version of that is
when you cry no it is no it is no don't
tell me how I feel don't tell me like
don't respond to my don't tell me with
your don't tell me I'm angry if I'm
emotional I'm [ __ ] emotional hey can
I finish this these people are Islamic
this is an arranged marriage
it's it's not forced just listen for
[ __ ] sakes gimmick it over binding the
monkey right they actually were allowed
to talk on the [ __ ] phone for a few
months okay okay so yeah these are these
are [ __ ] you know this is very
respected secluded life here okay so you
know she's her emotions are at the
surface so she cries if her little
sister annoys her if she feels she's
lucky to have me feels like her parents
don't value her or she feels like she
won't do me proud as a wife Oh
so whenever she's having emotions
basically right what's a good way to be
like honey I love you to death but could
you [ __ ] knock it off cuz you're
driving me crazy
how do you say that to a woman without
making a crime or
I mean yeah she seemed like she would
cry if you told him have you told her
like you know I know the tea was not
sweet enough so she's definitely a
sensitive I I told him to start crying
too yeah like she's just like I'm just
worried and I was thinking she would get
mad
probably because if she did it like that
because I well then she stops crying hey
hang in here for this last one I can
tell you as a man when a woman cries all
we want you to do is to stop crying we
don't give a [ __ ] you're selfish when I
yell that's an emotion you want me to
stop yelling yelling like hearing
somebody yell constantly is like
traumatic okay when somebody cry all the
time is also traumatic it's like you're
watching this sad movie that never ends
it is no that would be a real she sounds
like a real drip you know Jesus all
right well what can he do oh boy oh boy
buddy listen I don't know if your
religion allows you to do this but I
would get some boughs wireless
headphones the noise canceling ones Oh
whenever she starts crying I just put
them on and put on your favorite [ __ ]
music can you ask her dad or her mom or
whatever like just I just feel like
she's very sensitive she cries easily
you know is that so yeah I don't know I
would do that if they finally let her
talk on the [ __ ] phone and then
you're gonna come be like yeah you know
can you tweak her a little bit this way
anyway mom mom's comment on pizza leads
to breakup hey Bill weekly listener love
f is for family and all you stand-up
stuff keep up the good work all right my
question is what experiences have you
had with dating while going through our
up hey a rough time with your
professional career bill has never dated
anyone besides me I'm the only woman in
his life that matters and I really don't
appreciate you asking about the people
that came before me I got to tell you
something I dated a lot of great women a
lot of hotties there were absolute
animals in the rack my girlfriend and I
dated for three years and recently
decided to go on a break yeah and you're
breaking up we met in law school both
graduated with good grades and each
passed the bar exam the big difference
between us is that she got a job right
after graduation with a high salary
insane benefits and located in a wealthy
suburb this was largely due to a family
connection which she openly admits yeah
good for her use your connection
meanwhile I hope to get hired by a firm
I worked at during my final year of law
school but was told at the last minute
that none of the interns would be hired
you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god ft Sat
they're going through their card catalog
one of the [ __ ] as you guys do
as a result I've been living with my
parents for the past three months making
money teaching tennis lessons while
sending resumes and traveling for
interviews all over the state the
decision for a break came when my
girlfriend was visiting me at my parents
house she and I went out for pizza and
came back with some leftovers
my girlfriend put the pizza in the
fridge but my mom who has a heavy
Russian accent told her that putting the
pizza in the fridge destroys the flavor
I did not even bat an eye at the
interaction and went to the couch to
watch a hockey game these guys living
the life he's living at home he's
teaching tennis he's watching hockey
he's eating pizza I love this guy's life
after an evening of my girlfriend moping
around I asked her what was wrong
according to her I failed to stand up
for her and was supposed to tell my mom
to not speak to her that way well the
defense of her in defense of her though
the Russian accent is a little harsh
like happy and friendly towards each
other they sound like they're screaming
at each other they want to murder each
other yeah that they're gonna send you
to the [ __ ] gulag you know that [ __ ]
is true and like think about your
grandparents and your arms and your
uncle's like when you went in the room
nobody gets mad at anything on this
podcast Nia I have curated some of the
dumbest people on this planet and we all
just sit in our [ __ ] bubble of
stupidity enjoying all of this alright
after an evening of my girlfriend moping
around I asked her what was wrong okay
according to her I failed to stand up
for him was supposed to tell my mom to
not speak to her that way I know my mom
can sound a little harsh with her accent
yeah there you go
and sometimes uses incorrect words use
your imagination when speaking English
but the two have always had a good
relationship so there was no reason to
think she would be upset by the comment
this started an argument about how I've
become a mama's boy oh boy and that I'm
not and then I'm not desperate enough to
move out of the house somebody's gonna
throw a chair soon these comments really
pissed me off because she has personally
seen the amount of hard work and long
hours I put into my schoolwork
internship passing the bar exam and not
to mention she got a hookup and sending
out resume additionally this came a day
after I was informed that I was close a
close second for a job I was excited
about potentially receiving yes so this
is it yeah you see him branches you know
land is coming you like Christopher
Columbus Nia was commenting on this
all-natural ginger ale I actually like I
thought you guys been do I considered
ginger ale offensive an offensive name
yes you do
yes yeah people that follow me on
Twitter or know what I'm talking about I
did because I realized that I don't
consider ginger ale soda well it's
because you only drink it when you have
when you your stomachs nuts but you know
I'm
with ginger ale so I drink it all the
time but people seem to yeah why don't
you consider it soda
oh no no idea I consider soda like Coke
and or do you consider an apple of fruit
no why not I don't know super obvious
but I just never made the connection
that it would be soda if you said that
on a first date I would there would be
no second date I'd be like this is the
[ __ ] bimbo Jesus I thought I was dumb
yeah that might say that that story the
podcasts that girl one time okay you
want to go out you want to go grab some
sushi or something some night oh my god
I love sushi but one time I ate it every
day for like a month and what do you
call the white part of your eye I'm like
the white part of your eye it turned all
yellow and I was like yes and I
conveniently had another call coming in
that I had to take I still try to go out
with him I still try to go out with her
though you know like she was an
underwear model she modeled me undies me
undies no she didn't okay
additionally okay buh buh buh this came
because so the guy was excited women I
suspect the real situations my
girlfriend has an image of who her
partner is and saw potential in me
meeting that image someday but right now
I'm not living up to that image
it's like she's an NFL GM and I am the
potential franchise quarterback who
still needs to work on his arm strength
before becoming the starter in her eyes
boozing it up like Johnny football
instead I hid in the gym I gotta tell
you some dude I'd let this girl go no no
she's she's fun
the question yeah you can't knocked it
off - you know I gotta be honest with
you I actually thought this guy was
gonna do better with the question I
believed in his potential for this
question more yeah I think ouch ohh
I don't say I think your girlfriend
making a point here yeah so clearly it's
not about the pizza it's about like the
bigger picture for him and where he's at
in her life and she's not she is like
she's a spoiled brat who just got a job
gifted to her so she doesn't understand
why she's so like good at it though
right like it's it's not as if she just
got it and she sucks at it I know but
you know something he didn't he didn't
say that he brought that up because I
would have brought that up
still the marabous I'm sorry I don't
[ __ ] come from the goddamn Waltons we
were the Hoos a big lawyer family on TV
with the Waltons lawyers did you ever
watch the walls the Waltons was The
Cosby Show for white people it's just a
bunch of [ __ ] rednecks living in an
old farmhouse is like 90 of them they
all have [ __ ] overalls what do you
have against white people and overall
and [ __ ] dilapidated buildings good
night john-boy
whoever goodnight sounds good goodnight
Mary Sue alright Bobby Joe good night
john-boy
john-boy john-boy john-boy was like the
[ __ ] oldest dude on he was like a man
he was like a young man john-boy it's
his dad John - and he's John man he's
John man we're not answering this guy's
question I there is no question but I
think he just wants me to comment on the
situation I have no idea but I would
just say that I would support me when
I'm down how about you how about your
potential to be a loving and supportive
spouse like why are you kicking me when
I'm down like don't you think that I'm
trying to make it happen don't you think
I want to impress you don't you think I
want to be like you know the man that
like you know is is everything that
you've ever dreamed of I'm having her
time right now like you know why have
that [ __ ] for our debate when you
could just break up with somebody I see
too many red flags here too many [ __ ]
red flags there first of all they're
both lawyers okay they're gonna be
competitive they were in the same
[ __ ] field then it's bolson and she
gets [ __ ] pregnant and like who the
[ __ ] puts their [ __ ] practice on hold
you know I do obviously if she's
carrying a baby like that's kind of how
it goes
yeah like she should be loving so she's
like so get your [ __ ] together because
eventually when we have a family I'm
gonna have to take time [ __ ] [ __ ] she
she seems like the alpha male here in
this and I think that she's gonna want
to keep working and then this guy can
this guy can just [ __ ] chill out with
the kids teaching tennis yeah I mean
it's not like he doesn't have a job he's
looking for a job he almost got one okay
well keep at it keep your chin up these
people sound annoying
well how is he annoying get it to keep
teaching tennis yeah whatever
he's trying he's making money yeah but
she had to play it to teach it you're
like killing in your own head right now
I don't know what's going on with you
you find yourself very amusing all right
all right you know something all right
I almost started crying like that guy's
[ __ ] potential [ __ ] wife his wife
all right that is the podcast I don't
know if I helped anybody I don't even
know when I talked about I want to thank
everybody who came out Albuquerque and
people who came out in Tucson Arizona
and [ __ ] Dean Del Ray Jesus Christ
he's been [ __ ] murdering in front of
me yeah like people is like an audible
like no when he's when he's [ __ ] sets
over it's annoying he's making me work
out there he's crushing it Dean's the
best and I will be with the next Sunday
night up in Santa [ __ ] Barbara
I want to go go out and spend the money
that you're earning and go look at stuff
[ __ ] you and has nothing to do what do
you want to do in Santa Barbara I want
to go and hang out and see Santa Barbara
is how much does that cost hey with you
it doesn't cost anything for me to like
see ya cuz I'm paying for it paying for
what exactly a trip to Santa Barbara you
are working in Santa Barbara and I'm
tagging along with you like what is the
problem you just know what you don't
want me to cramp your style what are you
and Dean gonna go go dudes like skipping
to the vineyards together then I go to a
[ __ ] brothel what do you think we're
gonna do again you're gonna be there be
like ooh hope you wear a condom I don't
need that [ __ ] listen if you get ready
with that [ __ ] second grade
manipulation to try to turn the
conversation into that goddamn direction
I'm just gonna stare into it yeah
Barbara it's a beautiful place I haven't
been there in years like what is the
problem I'll tell what the problem is
because [ __ ] you because you only
because you only support me when I go to
fun places you're never there when I
need you when I go to when I go to
Sacramento you never want to tag along
potentially go to Sacramento I mean it
is the capital of what why would I go to
a not fun city like why would I do that
huh why would I need you to come along
to a fun city I'm already having fun you
love when I come on the road with you
that's why I traveled so much with you
before so yeah these are things I say to
keep the relationship going running on
your podcast like I like you don't enjoy
me being there with you and you're on
the road you're so in control and you're
just like the man of the family wait a
minute way
minute love when I'm there with you on
the road so knock it off time out time
out you're talking a lot of [ __ ] I
didn't get lonely on the road like this
until I had a daughter oh my god are you
are you see yeah when I did a three-week
[ __ ] run for the most part yeah for
the most part yes so then who you lying
to you know so you feel better that's
completely untrue
yeah have you ever seen what I do on the
road I go to steams I go to games I'm
hanging out with my friends I'm riding
on a bus it's [ __ ] tremendous the
whole game thing is you got to make your
wife feel like you're not having a good
time out there she's gonna get upset are
you serious
a lot of the times yeah no but now that
now that I have a kid it's different a
lot of those times all day and text
messages all day like I miss you check
this out isn't this funny buh buh buh
buh and like you that was a lot of those
times a lot of the times it's [ __ ]
not all but a lot of it is [ __ ]
I don't believe you that's how you do
the road as a guy I don't believe you I
will never trust you again if this is
true yeah you gotta say I'm gonna
Milwaukee I'm seeing the Henry Winkler
statue I'm going Fonzie
I'm going to the [ __ ] the
harley-davidson museum cuz happy days
was filmed in front of a live audience
to the audience there it's not like it's
rocky do they really have a statue of
him yeah like a waste of a sketchy
it's like the funniest thing ever a
waste of statue like the statue could
have been something else like what are
you to chop the head off and put [ __ ]
Merv Griffin's head on there is that
character that iconic that it deserves
its own statue hey that guy that's why I
love Milwaukee that's why I love Bill
walking that's why I love Milwaukee's
because they it's it's a city but it's
small town Oh Nia so me that's one of my
favorite [ __ ] cities I love Milwaukee
you know what Milwaukee you're okay with
me all right yeah this is the of course
I miss you on the road I love you I love
our daughter but this is times where I'm
really having a good [ __ ] time out
there yes I know so you have to text hey
honey I'm thinking about you I'm not
thinking about you I'm watching SEC
football I sometimes forget um married
when I'm at those games okay I get it
you don't have to keep like you know no
because you went so hard the other way
go like I was some [ __ ] pansy no I
get it
so it's self-serving pictures of you and
Paul virzi and and Joe Barton egg-like
arms-length
you know skipping into an arena of some
sort like so I get it I understand
that's our tradition we always skip in
yeah I [ __ ] rent a helicopter I fly
myself to Vegas it's [ __ ] it's a good
time it's a good goddamn time all right
this podcast is way too [ __ ] long
it's an hour and a half long all right I
okay can we apologize to the City of
Milwaukee I will on behalf
before we start a social media
controversy here all right I'm done with
this [ __ ] that's it everybody happy
holidays man happy Kwanzaa Happy
Hanukkah Merry Christmas all that shit's
coming up go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll
talk to you on a Thursday stupid